we are on the set finally of the Kelly
Clarkson show was this what you
envisioned when you dreamed as a little
girl like what I have my talk show no I
mean you didn't envision we've been
interviewed we've been like talking for
years years you didn't think this was
gonna happen either that's crazy it's
crazy
no it's a crazy I mean it's it's a dream
I didn't know I had and I mean it turned
out to be like such a dream job like I
love it I love my team that I'm working
with here I actually love talk you know
I love talking but it is different being
on the other side yeah how different is
it what's the difference you know I was
terrified at first in the pilot I was
like okay I got better throughout it and
then like we just taped like our first
two shows and I was really proud of
myself because I've been working on
listening and it's not that I don't
listen to people since I'm so
conversational so I've been working on
like you know really pausing and and
letting and it actually has been really
cool I've loved it so you have your
questions game together yes that why
bullet points and I'm old school I'm cue
cards okay here you go yeah
these people come on just close your
eyes and then when you open them I want
you to tell me what you would say to
this person in the first question you're
right
okay let's start with this lady okay oh
dang if I could turn back time share oh
my gosh
okay half are you really did you live in
Burleson Texas at one point in your life
because people lied to me if that's not
true somebody told me that you lived for
a moment of your childhood in Burleson
Texas where I'm born and raised in Fort
Worth but raised in Burleson
that's I heard that was true is it I
can't answer it but now I know that
first question right close your eyes
close your eyes again here we go ready
next one bang bang oh this is hard
Oh did you ever realize she's probably
been asked this a thousand times but I
have two questions when did you ever
realize the impact that you were gonna
make on the world like your footprints
that you have left behind for the world
that did you realize like when you were
it was that a dream or did that just
happen and and another question is man
you've been with seven a long time like
like
that's a long time that's hard to do in
this industry what is your secret that's
a question I didn't get I know it was a
man but I didn't see it close wrong okay
come on bang okay I really I honestly
would ask nothing about her job because
everybody's asked her all the things are
you're amazing when all the awards you
the best actor in the world great I
think it's fascinating that you have
four children been married to the same
man for how many years I don't know I
think it's like 40-plus or something
crazy about end time yes and I think
that is the most impressive and and my
eyes the most accessible thing that
you've probably accomplished because
acting is easy for her she's amazing
all right last one and this one's a good
one ready okay close your eyes okay boom
bang boom well that's gonna happen maybe
yeah okay so tell me
Issy and would you bring everybody
together I would bring everyone back
I mean novel she's like yeah we were
interested in things we could get the
jet original do G judges you know for my
season together and just because they
never thought this would happen
seventeen years nobody they didn't
remember me in the beginning you know
I'm saying like an idol like I wasn't
even shown until like way later in the
first season like so you know just the
fact that it's come to this point like
to come to version here it's pretty
crazy but I don't even my I love to do
my my cast like the top to everybody
yeah cuz I want people remember the top
ten I still talk to Jim and I think I do
like yeah um but I think that'd be fun
to have the top ten and on here and
everything I think the cool now look I
know you're working mom and yes busy and
you need to relax sometimes smoke so we
brought something for you I brought you
a little water gorgeous name by the way
yes you need that yes you need to put
that in your dressing room for one of
those days when you're like I need a
moment but how are you balancing you
have no idea how this is so funny
do you know that I I don't know if I
should say that's what I'm going to um I
was very specific about the gift that
would give away so the floods come on
the show because I was like I just
wanted gifts it with my name on it like
I was like I mean that's cool if you do
like one thing but I wanted to do
something was really personal for me
so I love wine so I'm giving away like
personally like picked wines and my
favorite vinyl and so it's a minute
glass wine with some music
yeah so so I'm gonna I'm not giving this
away this might not give it what no I'm
not giving this away but I'm just saying
that so funny you brought wine yeah why
I'm gonna be giving one okay I'm getting
everybody drink what oh so do you have a
room for our area for the kids where
they can come hang out play kick it I
literally just showed my kids like five
minutes ago their little area that we're
about to make because whatever we
started they they were like cuz I was
like man I have kids I was like I'm
gonna be working so hard like so many
jobs like they're like we'll create a
whole room and so I actually carved out
a little piece of my room that has a
little barn door whatever and it we're
setting it up for them you gave up some
of your space yeah well I took a myglam
was in there for right now and I was
like wait I promised my kids and I was
like and also like you know they're not
here all the time and just we'll have
meetings and stuff so I kind of wanted
the room for the family so that's really
cool yeah
did you see what you did you see the
Taylor Swift is now gonna rerecord for
music and it's because you suggested no
it is not that woman is the smartest
business woman I've ever seen in this
industry what she would have totally
thought about we actually ran into each
other recently and I was telling her I
did get that idea I got it from Reba of
Narvel and Reba actually Reba wanted her
collection after so many years and it
was kind of all over the place and she
couldn't get it and so she just recorded
them and that's why that's where I got
that idea because Reba did that okay I
hear that every day you come you're
gonna sing a song or at least the
audience can ask you and you will sing a
song yes what is the all-time favorite
Kelly Clarkson song oh it's not mine I'm
not that vain right but I'm know they're
not my songs I'm covering songs right
right but okay yeah if someone gets up
won't be the song that you like that's
my joint oh so many things pick a genre
Eddie genre like the one that you would
sing when you wake up and you're in the
bathtub you know Lori
oh well that's Aretha because in the
bathroom we all feel like we sing like a
real I would probably say oh god they're
so many I want to keep it up tempo so I
probably wouldn't do my favorite song
which as I've never loved a man like you
I probably wouldn't pick that when I'd
probably pick like something like pink
or something something with tempo think
yeah just some with tempo and soul but
that's that genre if it's another honor
it be a duffer oh yeah I totally
different vibe all right we got to come
back and have wine right all right
let's drink this I'm gonna save that
save it don't you lie to me don't you
lie to me I will I'm not wild drink I
will
[Music]